[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 21st of
april i'm john connelly the spectators
news editor and your host this week
on this week's show
boris johnson faced mps for the first
time since he was fined for breaking the
lockdown rules kyoda said his apology
was a joke and a senior tori called on
him to quit but the prime minister has
vowed to keep on fighting i'll be joined
by katie balls james forsyth and isabel
hardman to discuss his fate
after failing to take kiev putin has
started a new defensive in eastern
ukraine but can he convince ordinary
russians that the war is still on track
mark gagliotti and jade mcglynn discuss
putin's narrative war on the home front
in china the city of shanghai is still
in a grueling lockdown unable to leave
their homes and struggling to find food
people in the city are evading china's
censors to protest about the conditions
is there any hope in sight for them i'll
be joined by cindy u
and finally the next president of france
will be decided on sunday with just a
few days to go emmanuel macron and
marine le pen sparred in a debate last
night who won the clash i'll speak to
freddie gray and jonathan miller
before we get going a quick reminder to
subscribe to the spectator you can get
12 issues of the magazine for just 12
pounds and we'll even give you a free 20
pound amazon voucher too you can find
the offer at spectator dot co dot uk tv
offer and why not subscribe to our
youtube channel too click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of the
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
boris johnson was forced to apologize in
the commons this week after he was fined
for breaking his own lockdown rules the
prime minister said that it did not
occur to him that his dalliance with a
birthday cake before a covered strategy
meeting was against the law but will
that wash with the public
katie bulls writes this week's cover
piece on boris johnson's survival
strategy and she joins me now with james
forsyth spectators political editor and
isabel hardman our assistant editor
katie james and isabelle thank you for
joining us now katie you're writing this
week's magazine about boris johnson
fighting on he's had a tough week again
uh how do you do this week
well i think if you'd said you know two
months ago boris johnson is going to
receive a fixed penalty notice and then
have to face his mps in the chamber i
think you would have predicted that it
would be more tense than it really was
uh when boris johnson had to apologize
on tuesday he had one mp in the form of
mark harper the chair of the recovery
group come out and say that he no longer
had confidence in boris johnson and but
that was about it when it came to the
commons response there were a few you
know critical questions concerned mps
but there were more tory mps coming out
to try and move the conversation to
ukraine now obviously
figures that the government want to come
out and ask helpful questions don't tell
the full story but i think even in the
reception that followed where the prime
minister privately uh spoke to his tory
mps
there were two hostile questions which
point to trouble ahead but there's still
a sense that he is not an imminent
danger and i think for boris johnson and
his team this whole way through this
they've been focused on buying him time
and you start to see that the more time
that they buy for him the more chance he
has of putting through this now there's
still a few flash points i think more
fines are going to be particularly
tricky given the defense they've done of
this this line is so specific to the
event playing down the seriousness of
birthday cakes so what does there are
fines for what could be viewed as more
serious um real breaches and also
there's the sue grey report and there's
local elections but i think those around
boris johnson are more optimistic than
they have been for some time
james um as well as participate you
mentioned in your column this week that
boris johnson has got a lot of kind of
difficulties and trials ahead of him can
you give us a sort of rundown of what
those might be
i think the worry for the tories is that
it's hard to see where political relief
is coming from for them that there are
obviously all the issues to do with
partygate that casey just mentioned
then there is the fact that the tories
are behind in the polls even before the
next few months which are going to see
you know household budgets really
squeezed by rising prices um just this
month national insurance has gone up uh
and
then you've got a whole series of i
think what are going to be quite
contentious public sector pay
settlements coming and so it's hard to
see where the good news is and you add
into the fact that now the imf thinks
that the uk economy will only grow by by
a mere 1.2 percent next year
and you see it's going to be very very
hard sledding for the tories uh because
they're they're
people are going to be feeling worse off
and the government uh is gonna really
struggle against that environment i
think even i think one of the problems
with the government is that often in
british politics governments come in
do the difficult stuff straight away
become a bit unpopular and then if
things work out for them they reap the
benefits of that before polling day but
partly because the the tory offer in
2019 uh what was what was principally
about brexit rather than anything else
and also because of covid the government
hasn't done that so it is only now
trying to do some of the unpopular
things for example raising taxes
uh and it's doing that in the middle of
the parliament rather than when you
should want to do it which is at the
beginning of the parliament
and isabel do you think that sort of
creates a problem for boris johnson for
particular as well in that he can't
change the conversation
it does yes i mean he's been saying and
was saying repeatedly uh this week at
prime minister's questions and in his uh
statement where he tried to very quickly
address his party gate fines before
moving on to talking about ukraine that
he thought it was important for him to
be allowed to get on with the job and
that his sense of regret at receiving
that fine
had made him even more
determined to deliver for the british
people but but as james says what i mean
what is that delivery actually going to
look like because if you've got voters
who've trusted the conservatives largely
because they think they're the best at
handling the economy
get to the next election and they've
been through
you know a number of years of really
struggling uh to balance their household
budgets feeling like their money is just
disappearing much more quickly because
their energy bills have been going up
their pay hasn't been
keeping pace what will they have to
thank the conservatives for
that will enable them to forgive the
prime minister for his personal failings
um
and
even if
even if things were going swimmingly
with the economy the partygate
investigation isn't over yet and uh the
votes that we've been having um and
debates that we've been having this week
um on uh referring boris johnson
have been taking place before the police
investigation is over um before the sue
grey report comes out
and so there are many many more points
where the prime minister
where the prime minister could come
under much greater pressure than he has
over this particular find that he
received
and katie it's been sort of said that
boris johnson has been helped by the
fact that there's no real viable
candidate to replace him at this stage
how much do you think that sort of still
stands with the tory party and is that
going to carry on being the case do you
think or are other challenges going
through his merger at some point
well i think it is a big factor in this
as we'll just um explain there's there's
not much really to point to at the
moment in terms of things
to say that voters should be positive
about when you look at the cost of
living crisis um but ultimately tory mps
are looking around and they're seeing
the political pain that partygate is
still causing them which they do blame
boris johnson for but the fact they're
just not sure what replacement is better
means that many are just going to stay
of him perhaps begrudgingly
but for the time being until something
comes along and i think the fact that
richie's soon next popularity has
plummeted and mps are questioning how
committed he is to politics means that
he is not currently seen as someone who
is ready for an immediate contest i
don't think chloe's written him off
completely in the coming years but i
think a contest this year is one former
minister to me it'd be tricky for him
the chancellor to run in and then you
get to the other candidates um you have
figures such as sagittarius javad who
have has come out and said that he used
to have non-dom status after the non-dom
right um involving rishi's your ex-wife
and i think um that means that oh well
he looked like a safe option and now
actually
you can see how that could have more
pressure more scrutiny if he had a
different position
and and i think just looking across the
various candidates it is just adding to
the sense that almost you know better
the devil you know
and james you mentioned in your piece
that boris johnson likes to govern as an
optimist and do you think that's
possible now or do you think he's going
to be too slammed by the cost of living
crisis to do that and sort of salvage
his premiership
no i think this is one of things that is
difficult boris johnson is inherently a
kind of good time politician you know he
tells everyone that things are getting
better all the time
that that is his natural mo i mean i
think that's why he was never happier
than the the than the mayor of london
during the 2012 olympics you're in a
very very different world now and having
dealt with covid he's you know you are
now into a world way where you are
telling people constantly uh you're
having to kind of reassure people that
this this squeeze on their living
standards isn't going to go on forever
and i think if you strike a very
optimistic note right now it could
really jar with people's lived
experience and i think that that that
that is a big
challenge for him i think the other
problem for the government is that there
is still this fundamental question which
is you know what is the government for
now but it has an inverter commas got
brexit done and i think you know i think
the government have talked about kind of
leveling up has at times been cited as
the thing the government is going to do
but you know
even
after leveling up white paper and
and all of this i think there is still a
lack of meat on that bone it is still
hard to say
leveling up means these three things
which the government is currently doing
and i mean there is also a kind of
recognition in the government that you
know that public service reform which
was to go to meet and drink of british
politics for a long time you know there
is a real lack of um again
clarity on what the government wants to
do
to to change the way public services
work i mean that's a particular problem
because you've got these long backlogs
and problems caused by covered and the
lockdowns and education in terms of lost
learning kids who've fallen behind and
in the nhs in terms of wasting lists you
know you look at the fact that you've
got 6.1 million people on the nhs
waiting list right now you know that is
a major political problem for any
government let alone a tory one and then
you look at the fact that you know since
records sort of been collected in august
2010 you know you've got more people
waiting 12 hours to be admitted from a
and even at any previous time and i mean
the state of the of the health service
is is a potentially really big threat to
the government over the coming months
and as well switching to labor now i
mean it's wanting them to criticize part
a gate and the cost of living but do you
get the sense they're sort of putting
forward a coherent vision for the
country on their side as well and and
they're in a sort of decent position at
the moment
i think they're in a decent position in
terms of being able to prosecute boris
johnson's failings uh generally but
as you say what they are lacking is
any evidence at the moment to give to
the electorate that they are the party
to to rush to and this is partly because
of the theory that you know oppositions
don't win elections governments lose
them and um it's also partly just
because of the the way in which
uh the kirsten's leadership started in
the middle of covid's and so that crisis
has really sort of overtaken the normal
processes of party policymaking uh
to to his perhaps to his credit perhaps
to his detriment ed miliband was much
further along with making policy
announcements at this stage and it may
well be that actually that that didn't
help him um in the end uh because he
still
wasn't able to overcome
his uh his major weaknesses in the eyes
of voters particularly on the economy
and it didn't really matter what you
know tristram hunt his shadow school
secretary thought and that sort of thing
um
and so when you talk to those around
kyostama their argument is look you know
people were doubtful when we started
with this
um
this sleaze attack and with these
attacks on boris johnson's character at
the start of kirsten's leadership and
now look where we've got to so just you
know people need to hang tight a bit
longer but
but i think this is this is the year
where the nerves not just from back
benches but actually from front benchers
who want a little bit more to say
uh will come to the fore we saw that i
think this week um with pretty patel
versus yvette cooper on the government's
rwanda asylum policy
where cooper made some entirely
justifiable criticisms of that policy
which were echoed by uh theresa may
who's not exactly famous for being a
open borders former home secretary
herself
um but patel's rejoinder to this and and
all other critics was well they haven't
come up with any alternatives now that
doesn't mean that the rwanda asylum
policy is the thing because no one else
has come up with a decent alternative
but i think it does show one of the
weaknesses that labor has is that they
do tend to default on pretty much
everything to saying that they would
introduce a windfall tax regardless of
whether it's particularly relevant to
you know immigration or whatever
and katie in your piece you talk a bit
about uh reorganization in number 10 um
how happy a ship is it at the sort of
centre of government at the moment and
how is this affecting sort of boris
johnson
i think it depends how broad we're
talking i mean i think there's a tighter
team now so you have johnson's new inner
circle
and i think you're looking at their
inner circle you know figures such as
steve barkley and mp who's now chief of
staff as well andrew griffith is an mp
who's now had a policy if we give to
harry in charge of communication you
have david kenzie who's a crosby ally
and has made it i think a much more
political sense and and spads definitely
feel when they go to meetings they get
more direction and but then i think you
also have some members um who've been at
boris johnson for a longer period who
feel as though they're not consulted as
much are brought into meetings but i i
think generally there is a sense that
boris johnson's shadow whipping
operation straight after partygate and
the new team
event that they have managed to land
some announcements and for example i
mean people are still debating the
rwanda policy in terms of um those
crossing crossing the channel but i
think inside government i think that
that landed pretty well and actually
they do view as a success
and james looking forward to the local
elections in a few weeks um how
important are they for boris johnson and
do you think he sort of benefits now
from a bit of a low expectation
well we're at that expectations
management stage of a cycle where uh the
tories want to suggest that you know
holding on to one councillor in the
entire country would be it would be a
would be a good result you know it's
midterm it's always difficult for the
governments in these situations i i do
think that these elections
matter but in two ways
one
is that you know tory mps don't want to
do anything to rock the boat while
they've got council candidates in the
field i mean that's in part why the
reaction to boris johnson's been fined
has been relatively muted the the the
second thing is that boris johnson's
relationship with his mps is
fundamentally a transactional one this
is not a great ideological project this
is they back him because they think he
gives them a better chance of winning
than anybody else
if you get a series of election results
whether it be the local election results
and the wakefield bar election the
opinion polls nationally you know if
that sense goes
then i think boris johnson is in a much
more vulnerable position uh but i think
i i so i think that this is why the kind
of public opinion matters so much to
in terms of what tory mps think of boris
johnson because because the reason they
backed him in the first place was
because they thought he was a winner
thank you james thank you katie and
thank you isabel
putin has had to refocus the war in
ukraine after disastrous start to the
campaign after initially hoping to take
the capital of kiev and install a puppet
government there the russian leader has
now had to temper his expectations and
is now looking to annex the donbass
region in ukraine's east jade mcglynn
from the university of oxford writes in
this week's magazine that ordinary
russian support for the war is only
going to increase though the longer the
conflict goes on jade joins me now
alongside mark galiotti director of
mayak intelligence
jade mark thank you for joining us on
spectator tv
now jade to start us off um you're
writing the magazine this week about
support for the war in russia and how it
might actually be increasing can you um
explain a bit why
so of course it's very difficult and um
i would first of all like to just say
you know might should be the operative
word there has to be um some some some
caveats around um how we take uh even
the independent posters considering the
crackdown on freedom of speech and the
introduction of
several sort of censorship laws um
but my main argument in the piece is
that in the conditions such as they are
um in russia at the moment i can't i it
seems to me much more likely that
support for the war is going to increase
not just simply because of a rally round
the flag effect but also because you
know sanctions they are hurting people
um but they're not going to be blamed
nobody's going to say oh we have
sanctions because there was this illegal
invasion of ukraine they're going to say
we have sanctions because the west puts
sanctions on us and so that's not really
going to work against the kremlin and
then secondly of course um
there's the fact that you know of course
young body bags are going to start
coming home um or
or ashes as the case may be
and
people
are not necessarily going to react to
that um by being angry with the kremlin
i mean if you had a son and your son was
conscripted into the army um and he died
fighting in ukraine
you are not going to want to believe
that your son died as just sort of a
pawn in an evil war or even worse as an
active participant in in war crimes and
in terrible crimes and
then he was sort of just abandoned
nobody would want to believe that
narrative over such a terrible loss
you're going to be much more likely to
want to believe this alternative version
especially when this alternative version
is pumped every single day pervasively
by russian state media you know that
your son died as a hero fighting nazism
so it's going to be very difficult i
think i think the more loss there is
whether or not that's economical if not
that's these awful sort of tragic loss
of losing one's son
i think the more people are going to be
likely to buy into um to the narrative
and to be more resistant to learning the
truth of what's happening in ukraine
and speaking of that narrative mark the
offensive in the donbass or the warren
is going to intensify around the donbass
now um most in the west we sort of see
that as a bit of putin's failure of the
fact that he's failed to capture larger
parts of the country how is he selling
that domestically at the moment
well yes i mean you've got to realize
that
given that they're naturally going going
to spin the wars as effectively as they
can and yes they use
state-controlled media to do that
this is being presented as just simply
the next logical phase of the so-called
special military operation because of
course it's not a war
at first it was about demilitarizing
ukraine they bring out statistics as to
how many tanks have been blown up and
such like and then they say but this was
primarily it was never of course about
an invasion of ukraine they say it was
always about protecting the russian
speakers and russian citizens
of south eastern ukraine from the
genocide that was going to be visited
upon them by this evil neo-nazi regime
and thus what is actually
in military terms essentially
a
three-quarters defeat shall we say this
reconsolidation down in the donbass
region and along the northern coast of
the as of sea
is being spun just simply as a well this
is where the russian speakers are this
is where we need to be to protect them
i mean of course we we have to also
accept the the limitations of of the
sort of the capacity of the state to
spin everything as it pleases and i must
make here i would actually slightly push
back again against jade's argument
because in some ways look i i go back to
the soviet war in afghanistan
and if one looks there when again you
you have a rather foolish imperialist
venture
that was clearly being spun by a
very very powerful state propaganda
machine and the thing was that to a
degree people were willing to believe it
until they have some kind of independent
benchmark of what is actually the truth
and jade's absolutely right that dead
people tell no tales but the point is
there will be a lot of living people who
come back and particularly what we're
now seeing is
this is the new spring conscription
season
and that means that the conscripts from
last spring many of whom did end up
being pressurized into quote unquote
volunteering to go to ukraine
are now beginning to head home they
really started coming home the weekend
that's just passed
and with them there will be some degree
of tales of what's really been going on
and yes there will be resistance people
don't really want to hear
and people you know many of the
conscripts will not want to talk about
what they saw and what and what they did
but nonetheless i think we're beginning
only just now beginning to actually see
a real competition
between
shall we say the reality on the ground
and
the kremlins
on the one hand very sanitized and on
the other hand very very toxic
narratives about what's happening in
ukraine
jade what do you think about that um
what do you think of the limits of the
state media there in terms of convincing
the population
i think there are clear limits to state
media and um
i certainly hope that the
mark is right um
i suppose my concern would be that in
afghanistan it took korea took quite a
long time and i worry that nowadays
everybody sort of tends to expect things
to happen quite quickly i think because
of the nature of sort of social social
media and the way that all of our
societies are
but um there is a limit to what state
media can achieve however i think
perhaps
first of all i would say that i think
actually how effective state media has
been
has been underestimated for quite some
time i think if you use the word
propaganda people tend to dismiss it as
oh that's something one-dimensional but
one of the strengths of um the way that
the
um the putin government has worked and
and this isn't just a recent thing this
has been going on since i think well at
least 2012
and certainly before then but in a
particularly intense way since 2012 is
this co-creation i mean they're telling
even now the state media
is not simply imposing this view on
people this is a co-creation this is um
also in part sort of a narrative that
there was some appetite for and
certainly um this argument around the
idea that russia is essentially just
re-fighting world war two i mean world
war ii is something that is
is a cherished memory it's probably the
most unifying element not only of
russia's history but perhaps the most
unifying idea that russia has in terms
of an effective way of sort of bringing
the nation together
and um people people have bought into
these narratives um not just for the war
in ukraine you know long before them and
in many different ways that doesn't mean
essentially that they completely agree
with it in the same way that the kremlin
presents it um you know there may even
be some cynicism some of the people who
support the war are quite can be quite
cynical towards the kremlin some of the
more nationalist types um so it's not as
simple as you know people are zombies or
people are
sort of brainwashed but what it is is
that the kremlin is very good at sort of
creating this mosaic of narratives um to
sort of inscri that everybody can almost
not everybody but almost everybody can
maybe find one bit that they like or
inscribe themselves into
mark um jade mentions a piece about
these sort of state-managed russian
events in support of the wall for
example putin in the huge football
stadium talking to the crowds where a
lot have been paid for for example do
you think this is sort of a sign that
the kremlin is feeling a bit vulnerable
maybe and is perhaps a bit more wary of
spontaneous support or distaste for the
war
well yes i mean you have to realize that
you know when it comes down to it this
is a regime of old men who went through
the collapse of the soviet union
and in putin's case also the collapse of
east germany before that who have i
think an intrinsic mistrust of what they
would think of as the mob
and therefore time and time again
precisely want to try and get out ahead
as they see it and and exactly create
this astro turfed
fake notion of a groundswell of opinion
because the point is that these events
by squeezing out the scope for any
alternative perspectives what they're
trying to do is is create the sense that
there is a public ground swell and that
means that firstly a lot of people feel
well if everyone else is thinking that
then so should i
or secondly even if they are actually
personally feeling critical of the
regime
if they suddenly think well everyone
else believes this it encourages them to
keep quiet to keep a low profile this is
an era in which in some ways we're
seeing the weaponization of paranoia as
a sort of key element of control of the
population but i think there's also one
other dimension i throw in which is i
think in some ways
these kind of events are also thrown for
a basically an audience of one person
and that is putin himself
that this is actually an apparatus a
collection of officials who want to
please the boss and part of that is
precisely by giving giving him these
75 fake maybe but anyway these are
apparent expressions of public support
and people shouting and people chanting
and people waving the right flags
makes him feel happy and you know this
is this is one of the most dangerous
elements i would say the current
situation is that it creates this cocoon
in which putin may well be unaware of
the very real complexities of how
russians are looking at their current
situation and he just thinks well
everyone's behind me so it's a mix it's
important to a large extent it's about
exactly managing public opinion and
trying to create this sense of a
groundswell of support just as we see
with the now infamous zed symbol
um that although entirely meaningless
it's not even a letter in the russian
alphabet like that but nonetheless this
symbol is now sort of incorporated all
other places as you know officials
realize that this is this is what they
should be getting behind and ordinary
people think well this is how i show i'm
a patriot so there is the creation of a
national mood but it's also about
pleasing the boss
and jade you write a bit in your piece
about the russian state sort of
instrumentalizing trauma and um sort of
reminding russians of the worst areas of
of their history can you can you tell us
a bit about that please explain it
so in some ways it picks up quite nicely
on a point that
mark was making there about um
paranoia but there's been a sort of very
deliberate and again this is not
something that that started sort of on
february 22nd or after february 24th um
of this year but there's been an attempt
to i suppose
um that i don't think we can see is
anything but probably quite deliberate
um to use rhetoric that
and language and sort of certain set
phrases that um deliberately hop back to
the stalinist era in certain speeches um
particularly sort of some of the
speeches that putin gave him in early
march
and the way i personally would interpret
that is um
as trying to
sort of
stir up um
memories again this discouragement of
voicing alternative opinions um
and so on but there's also you know many
other sort of traumatic memories um that
um that sort of uh not just putin but
but the media as well can
instrumentalize and some of the most
obvious ones that have been used before
are the memory of the sort of chaos and
the anarchy of the 1990s
um when the essentially which in the
kremlin narrative is because of total
state collapse and having a weak state i
mean most of the uses of history that
you see in russia are about saying it's
really important to have a strong state
it's really really important you know
that there aren't any protests and that
the state remains really strong um and
so the 90s is a very useful one i mean
to a certain extent we haven't been
seeing that one as much as
we did in 2014 for obvious reasons which
is because of the state of the economy
um is such that it's very easy um to
make comparisons of the 1990s that
perhaps do not leave um putin and
and his government in such a in such a
positive light but there is this um i
think we're all familiar with the way
that um or most of us are familiar with
the way that putin uses
um the memory of world war ii and the
triumph of that and the heroism but
there's also you know a less explored
element of how he uses the the tragedy
um or what's seen as tragedies and
troubles and traumas to to encourage um
certain certain behaviors
just to pick it back
and i think one can link that back to a
very very useful point that jade made
right at the beginning which is that if
we look at the impact of the sanctions
at the moment
which in part seems to have been
intended by the west precisely to bring
pressure to bear on russians to make
them feel that they need to protest or
whatever against the regime that is
absolutely not what is happening
on the whole even russians who are not
fans of putin even russians who are
relatively west looking and know the
situation
when they go to the chemists and they
can't find the medicines that their kid
needs
or when they go to the supermarket and
they can't find food they are not
blaming putin
they are blaming the west they are
blaming us because we managed to launch
a sanctions regime which while
absolutely hitting these apex of the
state is also very much hitting the base
of society
and i think in some ways this actually
plays to
putin's use of national trauma and
national isolation as an instrument of
welding support the idea is even for
those people who don't like putin even
those people who actually may well feel
that russia ought not to be in ukraine
there is that sense that you are now in
an existential struggle for for russia's
independence and sovereignty
and a nasty west is penalizing you for
that and therefore like it or not you
have to again rally around that flag
i'm picking up on that point jade um
we're obviously not entirely passive
observers in this is is there anything
the west could be doing more to win
russians over and and do you think some
of the way we've sort of
uh treated russia might have have led on
to this for example this week wimbledon
has banned all russian athletes for
example do you think we should be doing
things differently
i mean there's two quite big questions
there um just to start with um i think
that i mean i completely agree with mark
that of course sanctions
are being um are going to be blamed on
the west and
it's not so much
that i think sanctions like that
shouldn't have been applied but i i was
i thought it was a bit of a shame to
apply sanctions that um affected the
entirety of society perhaps before we
had exhausted all of the sanctions
possibilities for targeting the elites
um i'll put it that way
um
i do think that a lot of mistakes are
being made i think that it's not a good
idea for us to um
firstly for us to sit in judgment from
well for me um and i believe for mark as
well from the relative safe from the
world from the absolute safety of london
it's not really for me to sit in la uh
to sit here and sit in judgment of
people um if you know for not protesting
or for protesting um because
that's not a risk that i have to take um
so i would just say put that kind of
element in as well because i think it's
quite tiresome sometimes to hear
westerners you know really having a go
at russians um
for not protesting but um yeah i think
that we should be trying to encourage
those people um who want to lea who who
do want to leave particularly the sort
of the young and the brightest i think
we should be making it easier for them
to come and to travel and to leave
russia because firstly that's a that's a
brain drain which will then weaken the
the russian economy further if that's
what they're trying to do or if russia
wants to have this kind of antarctic or
semi-autarkic semi sort of
dependent on china
system they're going to need quite
clever people to you know replace or do
all of the import substitution that they
that they now need so we should be
encouraging those people to come over
here to come over here i mean if you
follow that logic but i think also as
well it's just important in terms of
framing i very much do think that
probably a majority of russians support
this war um however i'm not sure how
just thinking from a western point of
view i'm not sure how helpful it is to
frame it in that way if we think back to
the soviet union it was a very useful
way of saying um
there's a tendency to say well you know
this is the soviet regime that's kind of
been imposed and there was this
difference this idea that had been
imposed on russia of clearly we can't go
quite to that extent but i think it's
important that we make sure people know
that there's a door open that there's
sort of a friendly hand being held out
because at some point
um it's
completely over optimistic as this seems
um
you know there might be an opportunity
putin might even die he might even be
mortal and there might be an opportunity
to encourage a slightly different regime
it would be very important i think that
putin is externalizable
there isn't
that there is this other idea of russia
and that the west has made it clear that
they don't sort of say well everybody's
putin
thank you jade and thank you mark
shanghai is about to enter the fourth
week of lockdown with many residents in
the city of 25 million still being told
that they can't leave their homes to buy
food cindy writes in this week's
magazine that the people in shanghai
have taken to social media to complain
and are using ever more subtle
techniques to bypass beijing's sensors
cindy joins me now
hi cindy thank you for joining us um
you're writing the magazine about
shanghai's lockdown this week can you
tell us a bit about the situation there
for those who haven't been following the
story as closely yeah of course so
shanghai like many other cities around
china has been dealing with an omicron
outbreak the difference with shanghai is
that it's actually one of the leading
cities in china which has been
advocating for living with covid or as
much as possible living with kovid's
strategy so he actually didn't lock down
when it found its first cases earlier
this year which meant that by the time
that it did lock down the authorities
didn't actually know how many cases
there were in the city a lot of these
were asymptomatic anyway so they spent
weeks basically telling people 25
million residents basically whenever
we're not going to lock down don't worry
then it did lock down at the end of
march and it split the city into two uh
in order to do kind of one week fire
break uh all the while saying this is
how long it's going to be and then it
extended that indefinitely and it's
currently still an indefinite extension
of lockdown but this whole messy nature
of the lockdown has meant that a lot of
people just weren't prepared for the
siege that then they're living under now
and
bizarrely chinese lockdowns these days
mean that you can't even leave your flat
in the tightest areas you can't even
leave your flat in order to get a
grocery shopping or anything like that
so it's created this logistical
challenge on top of the public health
challenge because the government is
having to arrange rations uh online
shopping is severely oversubscribed and
then there's just the sheer number of
infections that are happening in
shanghai at the moment and its peak was
about 27 000 in a day meant that because
everyone had to be centrally quarantined
on the chinese zero curve strategy um
that
actually there was you know just not
enough people to transport uh into these
quarantine centers there were not enough
quarantine centers themselves in order
to make this happen so the government is
basically dealing with a lot of
different problems all at once at the
moment
and you mentioned that there's some
quite draconian measures are they having
any impact at all on the virus itself
are numbers reducing is it is it worth
the the sort of the measures
yeah the numbers are reducing so at its
peak uh last week it was about 27 000 a
day but right now it's about it's a bit
under 20 000. so we do see it coming
down um but you know the government is
trying to get zero covert uh to happen
by the end of april uh at the latest and
that's just not looking very good at all
you know it's very ambitious target um
so the numbers are coming down but there
are also questions about how effective
these measures are because under xero
cover policy you're meant to kind of
quarantine anyone who might infect right
but at the moment what we're hearing are
these stories about quarantine centers
potentially having cross infections
where people who are testing negative
are put with people who are testing
positive creating these cross infections
or in these mass testings that have
become the norm in china um where people
are just kind of squished up against
each other in their social media videos
showing this and some people have
started refusing to go downstairs to do
these tests because they're worried
about getting infected during the
testing process um so there are all
these questions where you know just the
sheer scale of infections is something
that china hasn't seen before
and then they're struggling under it
and can you tell us a little bit about
these sort of complaints we're seeing on
social media and the kind of things
people are sharing about their treatment
in shanghai yeah so i think that's the
point i pick out most on my piece which
is just this incredible moment on social
media where so much of this chaos is
playing out online so that people like
me sitting in london chinese people who
are concerned elsewhere can see
everything that's happening and
obviously not every single person in
shanghai will be having a similarly
terrible experience there are those who
are very well resourced well to do who
can get enough food and who can get
enough medicines and who do have the
contacts so i'm not saying that every
single person of those 25 million in
shanghai are struggling but a lot of
people are and they're going to social
media posting phone record phone call
recordings of themselves talking to the
authorities posting videos of
potentially arguments with the police uh
similar things like that a bad treatment
like quarantine centers they're posting
blogs about
people running out of food people
running out of medicine and all of this
is just providing too much for china's
census to
deal with so at the during the time that
we're having these health workers
dealing with the omicron outbreak we're
also having china's infamous senses
dealing with a social media outbreak and
they're struggling they're really
struggling because the volume of
grievances is just something that um
you know that they can't keep up with
and there was this really intriguing
moment on the april uh on april 13th
between the hours of midnight and 4 a.m
which just seemed like the sense is kind
of clocked off a bit and people were
complaining about the chinese government
but under the guise of criticizing
america so maybe that's why it didn't
trigger any warnings with the ai that's
used to scour social media
but you know there was just this hours
of just completely unfiltered deluge of
criticism and um it was a really
heartening moment to see because and i
quote you know this one post in my
article saying this is the real voice of
the people commemorate tonight at least
i know that we are still awake though we
travel in the darkness alone there will
be a day when we have the force of a
prairie fire because people on social
media don't normally see this kind of
negative news but you know it's they're
finding it heartening that the censors
are struggling to keep up because they
can see that there are other people
struggling and also a point that i make
in my piece is that the authorities also
respond to social media so if you make a
complaint on social media even if it's
deleted someone somewhere has seen that
and we have seen evidence of the
government basically backtracking or
u-turning because of a social media
backlash so for example one of the early
things that the shanghai authorities did
was splitting parents and children
when they were going to quarantine so if
the child was testing positive and the
parent didn't the child would have to go
into quarantine by themselves even if it
was you know a baby or a toddler and
that caused a massive internet backlash
and shanghai authorities have now
backtracked on that so people know the
power of social media it's not just
cathartic it's also effective for
essentially people who don't get to go
to the polling stations um and the
authorities are actually afraid of being
humiliated or causing instability that
start from social media and so they try
to you know placate people and they try
to resolve these issues once they get go
viral
and you get the sense that this is
triggering outrage on a sort of more
national scale outside of shanghai
it's really hard to know but for sure
not every single critic online at the
moment are people in shanghai there will
be people who are you know complaining
about uh the inhumanity of the lockdown
not necessarily being locked down
skeptic completely but just the extent
and the inhuman nature that you know
some of these policies for example
splitting parents and children have been
carried out are um but there are also
people who are taking this as a sign of
you know the arbitrary power of the
chinese government and criticizing that
and those are not necessarily people in
shanghai but people who are watching
shanghai and you know i think it's
interesting writing about reporting on
this lockdown throughout the last few
weeks there's a lot of sheldon freud i
think from western uh readers and
observers you know haha china is now
dealing with its own pandemic but
actually for chinese people and you know
for people i'm chinese as well it's
actually very concerning you know it's a
doom-scrolling moment where you can't
tear yourself away from social media
because there's so many concerning
stories it's not funny at all actually
um and so a lot of people in china are
concerned that a this is happening in a
city you know the the most economically
developed city in the in the country and
that b it might happen to them later on
as well if something is similar uh a
similar outbreak happens so it's really
concerning and i think people some
people do draw political conclusions for
that i don't think this is going to go
anywhere though before you know people
wonder if this is going to be the
downfall of czech or the chinese
communist party i don't think it will go
that far because once they get this
under control chinese people have do
can tend to have short public memories
and they don't then carry that through
and you mentioned your piece as well
about people trying to get around the
censorship regime can you give tell us a
bit about the sort of the methods
they're using to sort of escape the the
hand of the sensor
yeah absolutely so first of all i mean
just to explain how censorship on
chinese internet works
it's actually the social media companies
themselves who carry out the censorship
they get briefed by the central
government probably weekly on what are
the banned topics and keywords then is
the social media platforms themselves
who employ either in-house teams or
external contractors professional
sensors if you will um in order to carry
out um these orders to make actually
implement them on a granular level so
that can be a manual millennials for
example who are apolitical themselves
but actually know far more about the
darkest moments of chinese history than
your average chinese person because they
have to be able to censor that they're
helped also by artificial intelligence
bots essentially who that search for
keywords also scour pictures for
embedded text in case screenshots are a
way to get around that
um and so people get around it by
avoiding keywords so instead of um
sensitive words like jungful which means
government in china people just write zf
because that's the first letter of each
of those syllables
to refer to the government and that
seems to get around that people post
pictures upside down in order to get
past the ai um an analysis of pictures
uh and there are also memes which refer
to things uh to people in the know so
for time
a picture of an empty chair was banned
on chinese social media when the census
caught up because users had started
using an empty chair to signal or to
signify the uh late dissident leo
who received his nobel peace prize in
absentia so the empty chair um and so
all of these ways people have of getting
around things and then also reposting so
you've got this
fascinating environment where the
chinese people know that they are being
censored they talk about the senses
openly and they also talk about the
methods of getting around the senses
openly so i read one blog um complaining
about uh the poster's neighbor who had
died of an asthma attack because he
wasn't seen at hospital fast enough
because of the lockdown and at the end
he wrote something like please if you
see this do not tag the government in it
do not tag any state media in it but
copy and paste repost because they can
take one thing down but they can't take
all of us down so you know it's it's
this
dystopian world where people know that
they're being censored and they're
trying to find all of these ways around
it and a lot of the times succeeding so
it's a cat a mouse game basically
and you mentioned about lockdowns
potentially spreading to other cities do
you think the criticism the government
is receiving now is making that less
likely or do you think they're going to
plow on regardless with sort of the zero
coverage strategy if it does spread
elsewhere so i think even xero covert
has degrees um because china has done
zero covered from the beginning from
january 2020 but what is bizarre about
the shanghai lockdown is just how severe
it is because not only are people locked
down and um
you know people contact trace and
centrally quarantined something new has
happened in chinese lockdowns which is
that those in the strictest tier in
lockdown in shanghai can't leave their
flats even to buy food and i think that
has caused a lot of the problems for
people locked down because
at the beginning you know you could get
these permits for household you could go
out to do family shopping every other
day i'm not sure why they have stopped
doing that and the city of xi'an over
christmas when it was locking down
because of omicron was the first to
pioneer this strategy um and that was
the first we saw government rations
being sent out but now shanghai has
copied it but it's not the case for
lockdowns across china so i don't
understand why it is at the shanghai
authorities themselves
have gone for this extreme version and
they have been criticized and compared
to other cities like shenzhen which have
had much more humane lockdowns you know
pets have been able to be quarantined
with their owners children with their
parents
it's confusing it's baffling actually
why shanghai has gone for this um
extremism and uh there's conspiracy
theories in china at the moment that
because shanghai was one of these cities
advocating for living with lockdown and
living with covert from the beginning
that there is this notion that they need
to be made to suffer because they refuse
to lock down now the people now they
need to be shown that that method was
wrong and they need to be suffering more
that is a conspiracy theory but that is
what a lot of chinese people are
wondering well how did it come to this
for you know the best to see in china um
so it is confusing
and finally before you go cindy um where
do you think shanghai goes from now you
mentioned uh at the beginning there that
this lockdown was meant to last for a
week do you think we've got met they've
got many more weeks ahead of lockdown or
do you think it's coming to an end so
last week um the city introduced this
tier system where the city was in uh
split into three tiers in the strictest
tier people can't leave their flats even
still for food
then there's a middle tier where you can
you know leave your front door and just
walk around in your residential compound
and then the most relaxed tiers where
you can go to other relaxed tier
neighborhoods um so
that's relative freedom i think for the
shanghainese at the moment but it does
show that the authorities are seeing
that they've gone through the emergency
level of the lockdown now um the
government has given them a target of
actually meeting this week zero covered
and the reason uh they can kind of come
up with a gold like that even though
they've got 20 000 daily infections is
because they actually count asymptomatic
and symptomatic infections differently
so in the official numbers they only
count a symptomatic infection as the
actual infection of course in western
reporting we add on the asymptomatic
infection because that is you know more
reliable so it could be that by the end
of this week symptomatic infections are
have gone to zero even if asymptomatic
ones are still uh around
but shanghai is hoping to shake this off
by the end of the month really um and i
just don't know if it will manage to do
that um the government certainly is
throwing all sorts of resources at it um
and there was talk before the shanghai
parties actually getting a promotion
before all of this happened but i just
don't think that's going to happen now
brilliant thank you cindy
and finally with the second round of the
french election on sunday emmanuel
macron and marine le pen faced off last
night in a televised debate who won the
clash and what's going to happen on
sunday i'm joined now by freddie gray
the spectator's deputy editor and
spectator contributor jonathan miller
thank you jonathan and thank you freddie
for joining us now uh macron and le pen
faced off in the the tv debates last
night um jonathan how do you think they
did
well i think uh most people scored macro
i'm a technical winner i sort of scored
marion the winner on the more emotional
level of
speaking a language that connected with
people
i think the expectations of memory of
marine le pen were quite
low
because in 2017 five years ago the first
time we had this rodeo
she uh was really crushed by a macron
she was not a master of the detail he
was
this time around he sparred with her he
jabbed
at her but he never really landed a
crushing blow and her mere survival
kind of makes her a winner so
i would say narrowly it was a
victory
for marine dependent simply because she
didn't lose or wasn't humiliated
and freddie how what did you make of the
date how do you think le pen did was it
sort of enough to survive or keep her in
the running i think there were there was
no winner really and i think uh for a tv
debate to really matter um they often
actually don't
i think for a tv debate to matter there
has to be a disaster for someone uh
there was a disaster for le pen in 2017
there wasn't really a disaster last
night macron i think jonathan may be
right that the pens have just about got
the better of him but he didn't have a
major balls up and that's all he needed
to avoid i do think though i want to do
a shout out to the sign language
translator for macron who managed to
convey his incredible arrogance uh
through his hands uh that was the the
star of the evening for me
i mean jonathan i think macron was
trying to sort of steer away from the
arrogant line do you think he managed it
at all this time or uh he came across as
a bit disingenuous
oh well he is a very narcissistic
personality who is always convinced of
his own intellectual
superiority and uh grasp of
the uh the actuality
um
so
uh
i think he probably was told by his team
to try to tone that down he has great
difficulty in doing so however i mean
you
can't count
a leopard cannot change its spots and he
was quite patronizing quite luxury
uh at times um
marine isn't a great spontaneous
debater um
she's uh not mentally very agile she's
not a plunge
she mastered her brief
um
her
responses to him were tempered she was
disciplined throughout
um
if he
looked you know at times like you know
the rat in heat she was kind of
the uh the nation's
grandma i suppose um
and you know somewhat more reassuring
actually
the dirty secret is uh it's a choice
that appeals doesn't really appeal to
the great
uh
mass of french people who voted for
neither one of them
overwhelmingly in the first two this is
what they're left with so the decision
is
is going to be you know who is the least
bad or among them and my guess is
probably this debate will leave macron
in
his leading position um
much less leading than last time when he
you know won 66
to 34 of the vote
um but he doesn't need that he you know
55 to 45 will do but
you know even when he's one it does
nothing really to resolve
the uh the fundamental problems that
afflict france which if anything are
getting worse with the cost of living
crisis
you know and war on you know
european soil
and uh french cities in turmoil
and uh
you know
potential refugee crisis apparently
across of living crisis
uh potential inflation crisis
uh in international relations crisis all
simultaneously
converging uh like a for you know uh
and and so to win this election is not
you know that you're going to have a
quiet life
i mean freddie you know since the first
round it's been kind of said that marine
le pen needs to pick up voters either
from the left or a bit more apathetic
this time do you get any sense that
she's managing to do that at all or is
it kind of has she kind of hit her
plateau now maybe
which she does seem to be performing
better in the polls with women and young
people
uh but the the latest polls suggest she
has sort of uh reached a plateau of some
sort
um and i just there doesn't seem to be
any evidence that she's going to be able
to win on sunday of course i stand i
could well be way off because there
could be a strong shy le pen vote
because of
mackerel's immense unpopularity but set
against that i think you have to do
there is a cost of living crisis which
le pen has spoken about quite a lot
but macron talks quite a good game on
the economy still and it's sort of
amazing that he gets away with it but he
does
and his grasp of the detail last night
in the debate showed that he's he's much
more competent at sort of presenting the
idea of someone who's in charge i don't
think there's uh i think freddie's you
know freddie made the point um that uh
that a debate in which nobody is a
decisive winner is not a debate that is
uh likely to be decisive
in terms of the uh the election that
follows
and uh this this time too
um
we still know particularly the decisive
winner uh we saw macron didn't fail to
put his opponent on the floor uh she uh
she she talked through his uh his
jabbings his probings
um
and so i don't think the final election
result will be particularly affected i
don't think at the moment i detect huge
momentum for her there's not a lot of
time left um it's uh it's it's the the
afternoon after the night before here in
france so it's the afternoon uh and and
the polls open at 8 a.m on sunday uh i
think uh the the
the result is baked in most of the
people i talk to uh expect macron to win
uh very very few of the people i talk to
were happy
with that
and what and freddie what do you think
macron's strategy is at this stage now
is it does it hold the line or do you
think he's got a sort of a bit of a
temptation to try and move to the right
slightly to counteract le pen
well he can't stop himself from uh
ostentation so i think there'll probably
be another ridiculous
photo shoot that will go viral he seems
to almost be doing those deliberately uh
but and i think he wants to convey
immense confidence
and he's pretty good at doing that uh it
doesn't matter how much you dislike him
as a person he is a pretty
brilliant campaigner i think we just
have to admit that that's true
well i don't think macron's been a
brilliant campaigner i i i paul company
with
with um that uh i think he's avoided
campaigning he thought that he that the
momentum of his interventions with uh
putin in the ukraine crisis
might uh put him in this kind of
olympian position as a sort of great
statesman at a time of of crisis
would carry him through and then when he
has actually confronted uh voters
face to face you know it's been a kind
of redux of the last five years he's not
really comfortable with people he kind
of says inappropriate things his body
language is
is is uh is sort of defensive he he's
much more comfortable in a kind of
professorial
uh imperious
role
preaching of people so i think his
campaign has been you know
quite uh
quite ordinary so far i think
even on the level of social media
you know marine has
shown more agility uh
a crispness that
the macro messaging has kind of
lacked so i don't rate his campaign i
think uh his calculation though
is that he's in a uh
a position where he he simply can't lose
i think i agree i agree that john i
think though there is an extent to which
uh french voters aren't really put off
by arrogance perhaps in the way we might
expect or even british or even american
voters aren't necessarily uh put off by
arrogance i think jfk said you know the
presidency is not a normal ambition
uh people expect
a global statesman to be
preposterously vain brilliant thank you
jonathan and thank you freddie
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you